we take the red pouch
the final call of Finn belden's shift
was to a patient who needed urgent
medical treatment
rushing him to hospital probably saved
his life it's why Finn became a
paramedic not sure we've got enough O2
left but Finn says the unrelenting
pressure and low pay have forced him to
vote for a strike some days you'll come
to shift and you'll be waiting at the
hospitals for hours on end just to hand
your patients over even if the patients
are very sick there's physically no way
to hand them over too it's frustrating
not being able to provide the care that
we want to provide because we don't have
the staff and the funding that we need
Finn is a member of the GMB the latest
health union to vote for industrial
action patient standards are suffering
now but that's not thanks to our members
that is a government that has
deliberately chosen to underfund and
under resource the NHS over the last
decade ambulance workers and paramedics
will join call handlers nurses Hospital
Porters and cleaners as they all prepare
to strike
one hundred thousand nurses eighty
thousand healthcare workers with other
unions are now ten thousand ambulance
workers that gives you an idea of the
scale of the protest that is building
against the government and that's only
in the healthcare sector and it's only
the beginning
University and college staff postal
workers and rail workers are already on
a list who are taking industrial action
with each ballot comes more pressure for
the governments I have nothing but
admiration and gratitude to our nurses
for all the work they do but but Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker it is simply
unreasonable and unaffordable to have a
19 pay rise
hunting now braces itself for a
difficult winter one that looks like it
will become increasingly harder and
colder with every ballot cast
our shish Joshi Sky News in Brighton